qué destacaría principalmente de las
recientes palabras del presidente eeuu
joe biden
un intento por posicionar la retirada
frente a los ojos de su público
principalmente y en el medio oriente un
intento de reducir daños reducir daños
porque casi todos los grupos radicales
islámicos que escuchan lo que acaba de
decir no se convencen demasiado ellos
salen de esta retirada muy alentados
tanto hamas hezbollah como por supuesto
y si se sienten que el gran serious que
sabía poner orden en el medio diente
ahora no quiere tener soldados en tierra
ahora como considerar que representa
este escenario para su vaivén crees que
es una suerte de derrota para su
administración dejar afganistán bajo el
control del grupo talibán después de 20
años de guerra
no creo que aún sea una derrota ni mucho
menos creo que es una medida inteligente
seria siempre y cuando venga acompañada
por dos elementos más el primero que de
alguna manera lo di a entender y es que
cuando haya una grave violación a los
derechos humanos o una grave violación a
la seguridad
entonces eeuu
entre golpe y se retire que fue de hecho
lo que hizo donald trump durante sus
años en el gobierno menos soldados en
tierras y más golpes de entrar y salir
cosas que tecnológicamente es posible y
lo segundo es va a tener que demostrar
hasta qué punto va a defender de forma
proactiva los derechos humanos en
afganistán esencialmente los derechos de
la mujer
y sobre esto hizo una referencia a
iovine en porque recibió críticas al
respecto a qué evaluación hace en abril
acerca de la retirada del modo en que se
llevó a cabo esta retirada de eeuu de
afganistán
era prácticamente imposible hacerlo de
otra manera o sea era por un lado un
poco ambicioso contarle a la gente que
estamos entrenando a los soldados de
afganistán y ellos van a hacer frente
cuando hablamos de un país que es un
país conformado por tribus que su
identidad nacional es menor y que hay
una constante competencia entre fábulas
entre clanes sin una identidad clara
como lo lo mismo vemos en muchos otros
países del medio oriente entonces vender
que esa estrategia un poco ambicioso lo
que vimos fue el resultado de algo que
se venía entendiendo y es que el talibán
combate con más intensidad porque tiene
mucho más convencimiento
eso no favorece al estereotipo de una
potencia como eeuu lo ideal hubiese sido
retirarse desde una posición de fuerza o
sea golpear y retirarse pero esto eeuu
no lo quiere hacer ni muchos países del
mundo lo desean y por qué
porque para un radical islámico lo
importante es la imagen y el mensaje que
se transmite
en este momento él radicalizar y que
está intentando demostrarle al mundo que
ellos no son los mismos que gobernaron
afganistán hasta el 2001 o sea se llama
un periodo de taquilla o sea de ocultar
la verdad
ellos entienden que si empiezan a
circular vídeos de mujeres azotadas
golpeadas y ejecutadas incluso entonces
la opinión pública mundial se va a
movilizar y va a movilizar a sus
gobiernos para que hagan algo recordemos
en muchos países si ha ocurrido eso por
ejemplo en el ataque de los aliados
contra libia o sea eso no lo quieren y
para eso lo que están haciendo es
transmitir todo tipo de imágenes de
ellos jugando los autitos chocadores en
un parque de diversiones o ellos
haciendo gimnasia o bien siendo
entrevistados por mujeres pero no nos
engañemos no han abandonado su ideología
radical
están midiendo la reacción de occidente
y yo creo que es creíble que el
presidente maiden diga lo que dijo
aunque es menos creíble creer que se
puede dominar al talibán con la
diplomacia y con la economía